Lorsqu'elles se déchaînent
de manière explosive,
les forces de la nature peuvent
produire des résultats dévastateurs.
Pourtant, dans
l'état actuel de la science,
la théorie généralement admise
veut que la nature elle-même
soit née d'une sorte d'explosion.
Il y a plusieurs milliards d'années,
l'espace et le temps auraient ainsi été
créés dans une gigantesque détonation
connue sous le nom de Big Bang.
Mais plus nous étudions
cet événement singulier,
moins il ressemble aux explosions
que nous connaissons.
Il semblerait que le Big Bang
est toujours en train d'avoir lieu
et qu'il va en s'accélérant.
Pour en savoir davantage
sur ce fascinant sujet,
nous sommes allés interroger
des cosmologistes de renommée mondiale
pour qu'ils nous fassent part
de leurs réflexions sur le Big Bang
et ses conséquences.
Dans la recherche scientifique,
les cosmologistes sont ceux qui ont
le champ d'étude le plus vaste.
Avec dans leur besace :
les lois de la physique,
toutes sortes de télescopes
et une curiosité sans limite,
ils ont dressé de l'Univers
une image pour le moins étrange.
Et la plupart sont des passionnés.
La cosmologie est
la science de la structure
et de l'évolution
de l'Univers dans son ensemble.
Comment se sont formées les galaxies ?
Comment se sont-elles agglomérées ?
Comment des étoiles sont-elles
apparues dans les galaxies ?
Comment l'ensemble a-t-il évolué ?
C'est vraiment la science de nos origines.
De même que nous aimerions savoir
comment les premières cellules
sont apparues sur Terre,
nous voulons comprendre comment
la matière de l'Univers s'est formée
et agglomérées en galaxies,
étoiles et planètes.
C'est vraiment un domaine fantastique,
un des plus stimulants que je connaisse.
La cosmologie a fait de rapides progrès
ces dix dernières années.
En partie parce qu'il y a 10 ans,
nous étions très ignorant.
Quand on ne sait rien,
il est facile de progresser rapidement.
Nous avons fait de
gros progrès en cosmologie
grâce aux données obtenues par
les nouvelles techniques d'observation.
L'avancée récente la plus remarquable
est issue des résultats d'une étude
menée par Alex Filippenko
et ses collègues
de l'université de Berkeley.
Ils cherchaient à vérifier
si l'expansion cosmique était constante.
Au début des années 90,
on supposait encore que l'expansion
de l'Univers tendait à ralentir,
à cause de la force de gravitation.
Si vous lancez une pomme en l'air
comme ceci, en allant vers le haut,
elle ralentit progressivement
à cause de l'attraction terrestre
et finit par retomber au sol
tant cette attraction est forte.
Et même si je lançais cette pomme
à une vitesse telle qu'elle quitte
la terre et continue de s'éloigner,
elle ralentirait tout
de même progressivement,
car elle ne cesserait jamais de subir
la force gravitationnelle de la Terre.
On supposait donc que l'attraction que
toutes les galaxies exercent entre elles,
ferait progressivement
ralentir l'expansion de l'Univers.
Pour savoir à quel point
l'expansion de l'Univers ralentissait,
l'équipe d'Alex Filippenko
se mit à la recherche de supernovas.
Les supernovas sont des étoiles
qui, en explosant,
rendent d'énormes services
aux cosmologistes.
Elles brillent en effet un milliard
de fois plus fort que le soleil,
ce qui les rend facilement repérables,
même au fin fond de l'Univers.
Par ailleurs,
un certain type de supernovas
que les chercheurs appellent type 1a
semble avoir toujours
exactement la même luminosité.
Elles seraient donc, un peu
comme les ampoules de 100 watts,
une source de lumière standard
à l'échelle d'une galaxie.
Dès que les chercheurs
repèrent le flamboiement
qui caractérise une supernova de type 1a,
ils savent exactement
à quelle luminosité s'attendre.
En comparant
cette luminosité théorique
avec celle qu'ils observent
effectivement à travers le télescope,
ils peuvent calculer à quelle
distance se trouve la supernova.
Or, la mesure de distance dans l'espace
est l'un des grands enjeux
de l'astronomie.
D'où l'importance de ce genre d'étoiles.
En étudiant des supernovas lointaines
avec les télescopes
les plus puissants qui soient,
nous avons été surpris de constater
qu'elles étaient moins lumineuses,
comme plus faible
que ce que nous avions prévu.
Ce qui nous a fait supposer
qu'elles étaient plus éloignées
que nous ne le pensions.
Cela signifie que la vitesse d'expansion
de l'Univers ne diminue pas,
car si c'était le cas, les supernovas
n'auraient pas été aussi éloignées.
Et cette vitesse
n'est pas non plus constante,
car les supernovas observées
n'auraient alors pas pu s'éloigner autant
depuis la création de l'Univers,
si elles avaient conservées
la même vitesse.
On en a donc déduit qu'elles avaient
peu à peu gagné en vitesse,
ou plutôt que l'Univers
s'étendait de plus en plus vite,
au lieu de ralentir
comme nous le pensions.
La nouvelle a laissé
les astronomes pantois.
Lorsqu'il aboutit
à des résultats tout à fait inattendus,
le premier réflexe d'un scientifique
est de penser que l'expérience
ne s'est pas déroulée correctement.
Mesurer la luminosité d'objets
très lointains n'est pas chose aisée,
même avec d'énormes télescopes.
De nombreux paramètres
peuvent fausser le résultat.
L'arrivée de courant
était-elle régulière ?
Les lentilles
étaient-elles bien ajustées ?
Avait-il été induit en erreur
par des phénomènes atmosphériques,
brume ou fumée,
dont il n'avait pas pris conscience ?
Nous avons vérifié et revérifié
nos observations et nos calculs,
mais les résultats restaient les mêmes.
Les supernovas n'étaient pas assez
lumineuses, elles étaient trop éloignées.
Elles étaient donc
plus lointaines que prévues,
donc elles accéléraient avec le temps.
Les malheureux cosmologistes,
qui avaient passé
la plus grande partie du XXᵉ siècle
à s'habituer à l'idée
d'un Univers en expansion,
se voyaient désormais confrontés
à une réalité plus étrange encore.
Toutes les explosions que nous connaissons
ralentissent avec le temps.
L'énergie se dissipe.
Les mouvements
s'atténuent progressivement.
Mais apparemment, à l'échelle la plus
grande qui soit, celle de l'Univers,
c'est le contraire.
Les galaxies s'éloignent l'une de l'autre
de plus en plus rapidement.
La nouvelle de l'accélération de l'Univers
a cependant réjoui au moins
un groupe d'astronomes.
Ceux qui, en essayant
de mesurer l'âge des étoiles,
s'étaient heurtés à un paradoxe.
Des mesures effectuées
à l'aide du télescope spatial Hubble
avaient déterminé un taux d'expansion
de l'Univers d'environ 10 %.
En intégrant ce taux
dans une formule assez simple,
on obtient l'âge de l'Univers,
qui s'élèverait à environ
9 milliards d'années.
Pour le commun des mortels,
c'est une période assez longue,
deux fois l'âge de la Terre.
Mais pour les astronomes,
c'était beaucoup trop court.
Ils étaient en effet convaincu
que certaines étoiles
avaient plusieurs milliards d'années
ou giga-années de plus.
Or, il est impossible d'avoir
des étoiles âgées de 12 giga-années,
si l'Univers n'en compte que 9.
Il devait y avoir une erreur
dans le calcul de l'âge de l'Univers
ou de celui des étoiles.
Mais les données
du télescope spatial étaient formelles.
Et les astronomes qui avaient calculé
l'âge des étoiles l'étaient aussi.
Il y a une façon très fiable
de calculer l'âge des étoiles
à l'aide de méthodes simples
de la physique traditionnelle.
Il s'agit tout simplement
de combustion nucléaire,
un processus que nous avons
maîtriser pour produire de l'énergie
et qu'on utilise
couramment dans l'industrie
et dans les laboratoires de physique.
Ce processus est très bien connu
et il nous permet
de dater les plus anciennes étoiles
à au moins 12 giga-années.
Or, les objets
les plus anciens de l'Univers
ne peuvent pas être plus vieux
que l'Univers lui-même.
Cependant, s'il est vrai
que l'expansion cosmique s'accélère,
il faut croire que la formule dont se
servaient jusqu'à présent les astronomes
pour calculer l'âge de l'Univers,
est fausse.
En prenant en compte
cette accélération,
l'âge de l'Univers
augmenterait suffisamment
pour rendre possible
l'existence des plus vieilles étoiles.
Les nouveaux chiffres
donneraient à l'Univers
un âge d'environ 14
ou 15 milliards d'années.
Ainsi, l'accélération de l'Univers
aidait à résoudre un paradoxe.
Mais beaucoup d'astronomes
avaient encore du mal
à se faire à cette nouvelle donnée.
Dans le domaine de la recherche,
un résultat aussi peu orthodoxe
et peu conforme aux prévisions
est parfois ignoré
pendant quelques années,
dans l'espoir que le problème
se résolve de lui-même.
Mais dans le cas qui nous occupe,
ce sont des chercheurs
d'une autre discipline
et qui travaillaient sur tout autre chose,
qui ont découvert
des preuves supplémentaires
de l'accélération de l'Univers.
Qu'on le veuille ou non,
un pied mystérieux
appuie sur l'accélérateur cosmique.
À quoi ressemble actuellement l'Univers
à la plus grande échelle qui soit ?
À peu près à cela, pensons-nous.
Mais ne vous y trompez pas,
l'Univers n'a pas la forme
de votre écran de télévision.
Il est d'ailleurs impropre
de parler de la forme de l'Univers,
car cela impliquerait
qu'on puisse le voir de l'extérieur.
Et ne cherchez pas à savoir ce
qu'il y a au-delà des bords de l'écran.
Personne ne le sait.
Tout ce que nous pouvons dire
sur la taille de l'Univers,
c'est qu'il est immense,
peut-être même infini.
Nous ne pouvons pas voir
au-delà d'une certaine limite
et l'Univers semble être peuplé
de galaxies jusqu'à cette limite.
Peut-être au-delà.
Mais nous pensons que l'Univers
possède une structure
ou une texture qui est la même,
quel que soit l'angle de vue.
Une texture semblable à une éponge
ou à l'intérieur d'une miche de pain,
de fines parois de matière
entourant un grand nombre de bulles vides.
Bien sûr, la matière qui sépare
ces vides n'est pas de la pâte à pain.
Cette matière est composée
de galaxies, d'étoiles et de planètes,
et d'une quantité considérable
d'une mystérieuse matière noire,
dont les forces gravitationnelles
affectent les objets que nous observons,
mais qui n'émet aucune radiation
que nous puissions détecter.
Et tout cet ensemble est
bien sûr en mouvement.
La cosmologie nous apprend
à quel point l'Univers est étrange,
ce qui ne doit pas nous surprendre,
étant donné que
nos intuitions et nos attentes
se base sur une expérience très limitée,
acquise dans un endroit
très particulier du Cosmos,
un petit objet rocheux assez
différent du reste du Cosmos.
Bien qu'il en soit issu.
Toute nouvelle découverte
nous en met plein la vue.
Quand Hubble a découvert
que l'Univers était en expansion,
c'était pour le moins surprenant.
Le phénomène d'expansion
découvert par Hubble,
est comparable à une pâte à pain qui lève.
La pâte elle-même, la pâte cosmique,
n'augmente pas en volume,
ce sont les bulles qui grossissent.
Dans l'espace,
il ne s'agit bien sûr pas de bulles d'air,
mais d'espaces vides.
La force d'expansion
semble être une propriété
des espaces vides,
propriété qui est contrariée
par la présence d'objets matériels.
Les galaxies ne sont
donc pas en expansion.
Pas plus que notre système solaire.
Ce sont les espaces
entre les galaxies qui s'étendent.
Il semble que l'expansion
affecte seulement
les parties les plus vides de l'Univers.
Et pour en finir avec
notre comparaison boulangère,
quelle que soit la forme
de la miche de pain cosmique,
sa composition, quant à elle,
est bien plus complexe
que celle du pain blanc.
En fait, l'Univers
est d'une complexité incroyable.
Il y a sans doute de la matière noire
composée de baryons,
des neutrons et des protons,
ce dont nous sommes faits,
et de la matière noire non baryonique.
Cette chose exotique
dont les physiciens parlent
comme s'ils savaient ce que c'est,
alors qu'ils ne l'ont jamais vu.
Et en plus de cela,
comme nous avons
l'Univers le plus complexe, riche,
intéressant et baroque
qu'on puisse imaginer,
nous avons quelque chose
qui comporte énormément d'énergie du vide.
Du moins, c'est ce que nous disent
les recherches sur les supernovas.
Tout ça nous apprend donc
que l'approche esthétique,
l'idée la plus simple,
ne conduit pas toujours à la vérité.
Parfois, il faut y regarder de plus près
et on découvre que l'Univers
est bien plus riche et complexe
que tout ce qu'on pouvait imaginer.
D'ailleurs, il est toujours
plus compliqué que ce qu'on imagine.
Ces dernières années, notre conception
de l'expansion cosmique a évolué.
Les cosmologistes la voit
à présent comme un conflit
entre deux forces presque égales.
La gravité, qui cherche à tout rassembler,
et une force de répulsion cosmique,
qui tend à tout disperser.
On pense qu'au tout début de l'Univers,
le temps d'une fraction de seconde,
la force de répulsion
a presque eu le dessus.
L'Univers a alors enflé démesurément.
Puis la gravité s'est réimposer et a
presque stoppé le processus d'expansion.
Depuis, celui-ci reprend peu
à peu de la vitesse.
Chez les cosmologistes,
ce scénario est connu
sous le nom de Théorie de l'inflation.
Il a été conçu à la fin des années 70
par Alan Guth du MIT.
La Théorie de l'inflation,
permettait d'expliquer toute
une série d'énigmes cosmiques.
Elle fit un grand bruit
dans les milieux scientifiques
et attira également
l'attention des médias,
même si ceux-ci
déformèrent parfois les faits.
Certains gros titres affirmèrent
ainsi qu'une nouvelle découverte
remettait en question le Big Bang.
Les manchettes font parfois
des raccourcis saisissants.
En réalité, nous sommes passés
à une autre version du Big Bang,
plus élaborée, améliorée.
On ne dit pas que l'Univers
n'a pas commencé
par un état initial chaud et compressé,
comme le dit la théorie du Big Bang
depuis plusieurs décennies.
C'est bien ce qui s'est passé.
On a juste ajouté une modification.
Avant la théorie de l'inflation,
on ne savait pas justifier le Big Bang
et expliquer pourquoi
l'Univers était en expansion.
Maintenant, nous pouvons.
L'Univers a été créé lors
d'une période d'inflation
qui a provoqué
une forte expansion initiale,
dont l'expansion actuelle
est la conséquence.
À ses débuts,
l'Univers était
extrêmement chaud et dense.
Si dense que toute la matière et l'énergie
étaient compressées en
une sorte de plasma presque inerte.
Mais pas complètement inerte.
En effet, il était parcouru
de fluctuations aléatoires,
provoquant par endroits
des variations infimes de densité.
Ces variations augmentèrent avec le temps.
Finalement, les parties les plus denses
devinrent des galaxies
et des amas de galaxies.
Et les régions les moins denses
devinrent ces fameux vides cosmiques
dont la croissance provoque
l'expansion de l'Univers.
Au départ ces vides n'étaient
pas aussi grands que maintenant
et les parties matériels du Cosmos :
les galaxies, les étoiles et les planètes
étaient bien plus rapprochées.
Leur attraction gravitationnelle
réciproque
fut d'abord un frein à l'expansion,
mais il semblerait que
les plaquettes de ce frein cosmique
soient en train de s'user.
À mesure que la distance
entre deux galaxies augmente,
l'attraction gravitationnelle
entre elles diminue.
Mais la tendance de l'espace vide
à s'agrandir reste constante.
Progressivement donc,
la gravité perd la partie.
Et l'expansion accélère.
Ce champ de recherche est si récent
que les experts ne se sont
pas encore mis d'accord
sur le nom à donner
à cette force de répulsion cosmique.
Ce point fait même l'objet de vifs débats
lors des conférences scientifiques.
Certains l'appellent L'énergie du vide
ou La fausse énergie du vide.
D'autres parlent
de constante cosmologique.
Enfin, un nombre croissant de chercheurs
l'appellent simplement L'énergie noire.
Mais quel que soit son nom,
elle a un impact profond
sur le devenir de l'Univers.
S'il existe autant d'énergie noire
que le suggèrent nos observations,
alors l'avenir de l'Univers est assuré.
Il ne se contractera jamais.
Il poursuivra son expansion
de plus en plus rapidement
jusqu'à ce que d'ici quelques centaines
de milliards d'années,
il n'y ait à peu près
plus rien nulle part.
Tout sera extrêmement dispersé
et les étoiles auront toutes
achevées leur combustion.
L'Univers sera froid, sombre et vide,
ce qui pour beaucoup
est une idée terrifiante.
Mais la dissolution de l'Univers
ne sera pas un problème
pour l'espèce humaine.
Dans quelques centaines
de milliards d'années,
le soleil aura depuis longtemps disparu
et la Terre, s'il en reste quelque chose,
ne sera guère plus
qu'une relique calcinée et gelée.
Il n'y aura donc pas d'humains
pour observer l'extinction des étoiles
et la fuite des galaxies.
Et c'est peut-être aussi bien ainsi.
Tout être doué de raison qui
existerait encore dans ce lointain futur,
se trouverait en effet
face à un spectacle assez désolant.
Effectivement, d'un point
de vue astronomique,
l'avenir lointain de l'Univers
est assez sombre.
L'expansion de l'Univers
continuera d'accélérer
et les galaxies, que la gravité
ne relie pas à la voie lactée,
disparaîtront de notre vue,
parce qu'il y aura tellement d'espace
entre nous et ces galaxies,
que leur lumière
ne pourra plus nous parvenir.
Il y a 100 ans,
personne ne s'imaginait encore
que le Cosmos enflait comme un ballon.
Et dans l'entre deux guerres, Edwin Hubble
ne s'y attendait pas non plus
lorsqu'il entreprit de mesurer
le mouvement des galaxies.
Il ignorait que les chercheurs passeraient
une bonne partie du XXᵉ siècle
à tenter de comprendre cette expansion.
Et personne n'aurait pu deviner
qu'ils ne parviendraient à l'expliquer
que grâce à l'erreur de jugement
d'un savant encore plus important.
Les chercheurs n'étaient pas préparés
à un Univers dont
l'expansion va en accélérant.
Ils ont donc commencé à se demander
s'ils étaient sur la bonne voie.
Rappelez-vous que
l'idée d'un Univers en accélération
est venue d'un projet visant
à mesurer la distance de supernovas
situées à plusieurs
milliards d'années lumière.
Une erreur a-t-elle été commise
lors de ces mesures ?
Les experts étudient
de très près la question
car dans le domaine scientifique,
on se doit de chercher les failles
de chaque nouvelle théorie.
Une personne sceptique, ou tout simplement
douée de bon sens demanderait :
"Comment savez-vous que les supernovas
que vous voyez à 5 milliards
d'années lumière,
sont les mêmes
que celles toutes proches
qui vous servent de comparaison
pour vos mesures ?"
Pour déterminer
les propriétés de ces supernovas,
nous analysons leur spectre lumineux.
Et nous le comparons ensuite à celui des
supernovas qui sont plus proches.
Pour autant que nous sachions,
nous n'avons pas décelé
de différences entre les spectres.
Ce qui est très encourageant.
Le spectre dépend en effet
de la composition chimique,
de la vitesse de l'explosion,
de la température.
Beaucoup de facteurs interviennent.
Si les deux spectres concordent,
cela nous permet de supposer
qu'il s'agit du même type d'objet.
Les interrogations sur l'expansion
cosmique remontent à loin.
On peut dire que tout a commencé
avec Albert Einstein,
il y a environ un siècle.
C'est lui qui le premier, émis l'idée
d'une force de répulsion cosmique
qu'il nomma Constante cosmologique.
Mais peu de temps après,
pris de doutes, il rejeta cette hypothèse.
Cette histoire est l'anecdote préférée
des cosmologistes
qui la racontent volontiers.
Il est intéressant de noter
que l'idée que la force
d'attraction de la gravité
puisse être contrebalancée par une sorte
de nature élastique de l'Univers,
est venue à Einstein en 1916.
En 1916, sa théorie
de la relativité généralisée
a montré que l'Univers pouvait être
soit en expansion, soit en contraction,
mais qu'en aucun cas
il ne pouvait être statique.
Il y a une sorte d'ironie tragique
dans le travail d'Einstein
sur la constante cosmologique.
Il faut l'imaginer
en plein hiver à Berlin,
alors que la guerre
faisait rage dans les tranchées.
Laissé à lui-même et marginalisé
pour ses positions pacifistes.
Assis à son bureau, penché
sur ses équations décrivant l'Univers,
il a dû être terrifié de découvrir
qu'elles impliquaient que l'Univers
devait être en train
de se contracter ou de s'étendre.
La force d'attraction de la gravité
aurait provoqué
l'effondrement de l'Univers.
Alors, pour contourner ce problème,
il a doté le vide, l'espace vide,
d'une force de répulsion
qui s'opposait à la gravité.
Il a travaillé ses équations
jusqu'à ce qu'il trouve qu'une des
valeurs possibles de la constante
pouvait équilibrer l'Univers,
de sorte qu'il ne soit ni en train
de s'étendre ni de se contracter.
Mais à y bien réfléchir,
Einstein s'aperçut que
cette constante cosmologique
ne maintenait pas vraiment
l'Univers en équilibre.
En fait, elle rendait
tout l'ensemble instable.
Au moindre choc, le Cosmos tout entier
s'effondrerait sous son propre poids
ou volerait en éclat.
Einstein se dit
que c'était tout bonnement impossible.
Il cherchait encore un moyen d'aboutir
à un Univers permanent et immuable.
Mais si la force de répulsion cosmique
n'était pas la solution, alors quoi ?
Ce n'était pas seulement énigmatique,
c'était embarrassant.
Einstein a dû s'écrier :
"Oh mon dieu, c'est terrible !"
Il paraît qu'il a dit que
c'était la plus grande erreur de sa vie.
Ça aurait été la quatrième prédiction
de sa théorie de la relativité.
Et probablement la plus spectaculaire.
Mais même Einstein
ne pouvait aller jusque-là
et tirer les conséquences
ultimes de sa théorie en disant :
"Si ça prédit que l'Univers
doit être en expansion,
il doit l'être nom de Dieu."
C'était inconcevable pour lui à l'époque.
Au début du XXᵉ siècle,
il paraissait évident
à la plupart des gens
que l'Univers était éternel et immuable.
Même Einstein avait du mal
à dépasser cet a priori.
Ce manque d'imagination, surprenant
de la part d'un homme comme lui,
lui a peut-être fait rater
un deuxième prix Nobel.
Mais un autre chercheur
allait tout remettre en cause.
L'édifice conceptuel d'Einstein
s'écroula en effet en 1929,
lorsque Edwin Hubble annonça que
l'Univers n'était ni stable ni immuable.
Le Cosmos était en expansion
à la suite d'un cataclysme originel,
qu'aujourd'hui nous appelons le Big Bang.
Dans la communauté scientifique,
cette nouvelle fit l'effet d'une bombe.
Einstein, lui, dû pousser
un soupir de soulagement
et rangea sa constante
cosmologique au fond d'un tiroir.
Le travail de Hubble était si rigoureux,
que l'idée au départ extravagante
d'un Univers en expansion
fut rapidement accepté.
En quelques années,
les astronomes s'habituèrent à considérer
l'Univers comme un milieu dynamique
avec un passé dramatique.
Il semblait désormais vain
de trafiquer les équations
pour obtenir un Univers stable.
Vers 1930, nombre de
scientifiques étaient convaincus
que nous vivions
dans un Univers en expansion
et que la constante
cosmologique était inutile.
Et beaucoup de gens ayant entendu dire
qu'Einstein avait reconnu
que c'était sa plus grande bourde,
pensaient qu'il ne fallait
plus toucher à cette constante.
C'était une très mauvaise idée,
presque un sujet tabou
pour les théoriciens,
et il ne fallait plus y toucher.
Car qui aurait voulu défendre
la constante cosmologique
aurait eu l'air de dire
qu'il était plus malin qu'Einstein,
ce qui bien sûr était possible,
mais tout de même assez improbable.
La plus grande erreur d'un génie
peut s'avérer utile aux autres.
Il semblerait que l'Univers
possède bien quelque chose
comme une constante cosmologique,
qui provoque l'accélération
de son expansion.
Malgré le prestige d'Einstein,
ou peut-être à cause de ce prestige,
l'idée d'une force de répulsion cosmique
aurait pu sombrer dans l'oubli.
Mais de nouvelles observations allaient
bientôt fournir des preuves décisives
qui allaient fini
par renverser la vapeur.
Pour rassembler ces preuves,
une équipe de chercheurs a décidé de
partir littéralement au bout du monde.
Au tout début, l'Univers était si dense
que la matière et l'énergie
ne pouvaient avoir les formes
sous lesquelles
nous les connaissons aujourd'hui.
Elles étaient regroupées
dans une sorte d'état supérieur mystérieux
que nous ne pouvons
reproduire en laboratoire.
Mais après 300 000 ans d'expansion,
la densité se réduisit suffisamment pour
permettre à la matière et à l'énergie
de prendre leur forme respective.
Il y eut alors un éclair fulgurant,
plus lumineux que la surface du soleil
et dont la lumière illumine encore
chaque recoin de l'Univers.
Depuis, le Cosmos
s'étant énormément étendu,
les longueurs d'onde de cette lumière
se sont décalées vers le rouge
et se sont dilués dans l'espace.
Pour les visualiser aujourd'hui,
il nous faut observer les micro-ondes
dans le spectre lumineux,
en utilisant des appareils
extrêmement sensibles.
Les premiers à le faire furent Arnaud
Penzias et Robert Wilson en 1965.
En recherchant l'origine du bruit radio
dans le réseau téléphonique,
ils firent une découverte inattendue
qui leur valut le prix Nobel en 1978.
Le fond de rayonnement cosmologique
est considéré comme la preuve
la plus irréfutable du Big Bang.
Et jusqu'à la fin du XXᵉ siècle,
on se contenta de savoir qu'il s'agissait
de la rémanence de l'éclair originel.
À première vue,
le fond de rayonnement cosmologique
semblait parfaitement égal et uniforme.
Mais les recherches théoriques prédisaient
qu'en poussant les observations,
on devrait distinguer une trame de zone
plus claire et plus sombre,
indiquant des écarts
de température de l'éclair
de quelques millionièmes
de degrés.
Si l'on pouvait détecter
cette trame et la mesurer,
on pourrait connaître
la géométrie de l'espace.
Ceci nous permettrait de déterminer
la quantité de matière et d'énergie
qui le compose et de connaître le sort
qui sera celui de l'Univers.
À la fin du XXᵉ siècle,
de nombreuses équipes de chercheurs
ont tenté de mettre en évidence
ce faible signal du rayonnement.
Mais ce n'était pas une tâche facile.
Plus de 20 ans se sont écoulés
avant que quelqu'un y parvienne.
Ce n'est qu'au cours de la mission COBE,
un très beau projet
de la NASA amorcé en 1989,
que des scientifiques
ont enfin réussi à mesurer des rides
dans le fonds de rayonnement cosmologique.
Cette découverte a enthousiasmé
toute la communauté scientifique
lorsqu'elle a été annoncée en 1990.
Après ça, d'autres expériences
ont suivi au cours des années 90.
Les plus concluantes datent
d'il y a à peine quelques années.
Il s'agit de Maxima et de Boomerang.
Toutes deux ont permis
de déceler les rides
de l'ordre d'environ
un degré dans le ciel.
Ces rides sont incontestables.
Elles correspondent
aux prédictions des théoriciens
et ont d'énormes implications sur notre
conception de la structure de l'Univers.
Et comment mesure-t-on les rides
dans l'espace temps ?
Une équipe, celle de la mission Boomerang,
a décidé que le mieux pour cela
était de partir en Antarctique
pour y faire voler un ballon.
Une idée moins folle
qu'on pourrait croire.
Ils ont accroché un radiotélescope
à un ballon qui a survolé le pôle Sud.
Cette mission avait deux atouts.
Le premier était une nouvelle
génération de détecteurs,
bien plus sensibles que les précédents.
Le deuxième atout de cette mission
a été le choix de l'Antarctique.
Le télescope à micro-ondes
est sensible à des fréquences
qui sont absorbées par
la vapeur d'eau de l'atmosphère.
Or, en Antarctique, il fait si froid
que l'air contient très peu d'humidité.
Et le ballon permettait de monter
l'instrument au-dessus de cette humidité.
Pour obtenir la plus
grande précision possible,
il fallait en outre que
les détecteurs de micro-ondes
aient un très long temps
d'exposition à une altitude constante.
Là aussi, l'Antarctique
était le terrain idéal.
D'habitude, les ballons montent durant
la journée lorsqu'ils se réchauffent
et redescendent le soir
lorsqu'ils se refroidissent.
Mais au pôle Sud,
la température de l'air peut être stable
pendant des jours et des jours.
L'équipe Boomerang
a donc pu prendre une image du ciel
avec une exposition de 10 jours,
soit 20 fois plus longtemps
que ce qui avait été fait auparavant.
Résultat, une précision
de l'ordre du millionième.
C'est ainsi qu'on a pu obtenir
cet incroyable résultat.
On peut voir sur l'image
que les tâches chaudes
sont séparées les unes des autres
par des variations d'environ un degré.
Et une théorie très simple,
affirme que la distance moyenne
entre ces grandes tâches chaudes
vous indique la courbure de l'Univers.
L'important à propos
de cette image du projet Boomerang,
ce ne sont pas
les tâches prises séparément,
mais c'est la taille de la trame
que ces tâches forme.
Les théories cosmologiques actuelles
prédisent un certain espacement
entre les tâches claires,
mais elles prédisent
aussi que cet espacement
peut apparaître plus ou moins grand
selon la courbure de l'espace.
Qu'entend-on par courbure de l'espace ?
Prenons deux lignes parallèles.
Nous apprenons à l'école
qu'elles ne se rencontrent jamais.
Mais cela n'est vrai
que si l'espace est plat.
S'il possède une courbure dite positive,
les deux lignes finiront par se rejoindre.
Et en cas de courbure négative,
les lignes s'écarteront progressivement.
Dans les deux cas,
la courbure de l'espace
a un effet important
sur notre perception des objets
situés à grande distance.
Elle agit comme une lentille déformante
entre nous et le Cosmos.
Pourtant,
il ne semble y avoir aucune distorsion
dans le fond de rayonnement.
Les tâches semblent avoir
exactement la taille prévue,
ce qui indique que l'Univers
dans lequel nous vivons n'est pas courbe,
mais parfaitement plat.
Deux lignes parallèles
le resteront donc éternellement.
Mais il reste un problème.
C'est la quantité d'énergie
et de matière qu'il contient
qui détermine si l'espace
est plat ou courbe.
Et nos théories nous apprennent
combien il doit y avoir de matière
dans chaque année lumière cube,
pour que l'espace soit aussi plat
que ce que disent nos observations.
Et c'est là que les choses se corsent.
Malgré tous leurs efforts,
les chercheurs n'ont pu trouver
qu'un tiers de cette quantité de matière,
même en comptant
la mystérieuse matière noire
dont nous connaissons l'existence,
mais que nous ne pouvons visualiser.
Il semble donc n'y avoir pas assez
de matière dans l'Univers
pour que celui-ci soit plat.
Pour déterminer la densité de l'Univers,
nous avons additionné toutes les galaxies
et multiplié cette somme
par la quantité de matière noire
pour trouver une sorte
de moyenne de la densité.
Et nous avons obtenu un tiers
de la valeur prévue par la théorie.
Pendant un moment les théoriciens,
avec un sourire pincé,
on dit :
"C'est un travail très difficile."
"Pourquoi ne reprenez-vous
pas vos calculs ?"
"La bonne réponse est un
et vous ne trouvez qu'un tiers."
"Continuez de chercher."
Il y a donc eu d'autres calculs
qui donnaient toujours
le même résultat d'un tiers.
L'Univers peut être rendu plat
par une quantité suffisante
de matière ou d'énergie.
Donc si l'Univers est plat,
alors que la quantité
de matière est trop réduite,
il doit y avoir dans l'espace
une source immense d'énergie
qui jusqu'à présent,
n'a jamais été détectée.
Vers 1995, les scientifiques
étaient sérieusement ennuyés
par cette valeur prévue de un
et celle observée d'un tiers.
Alors que les observations
n'avaient pas l'air d'être erronées
et restaient constantes.
Certains ont donc fait appel au puissant
moyen théorique qu'est la soustraction,
en disant :
"Si le total souhaité est un
et que nous n'observons qu'un tiers,
alors il manque deux tiers quelque part."
Et d'aucuns ont été
assez courageux pour dire :
"Peut-être s'agit-il
de la constante cosmologique."
Or, c'est à peu près au même moment
que sont arrivées les données
sur les supernovas.
Dès 1997-1998,
il semblait clair que ces données
suggéraient une accélération
qu'on pouvait attribuer
à cette chose étrange
qu'Einstein avait inventé en 1916
pour de toutes autres raisons.
À savoir : Une force qui pousse
l'Univers à s'étendre,
s'opposant à celle de la gravité.
On dirait que pour la première fois, nous
abordons le problème de la bonne façon
ou du moins, nous commençons
à comprendre quel est le problème.
J'ai l'impression que les volets
s'ouvrent d'un seul coup
et que nous avons enfin une vue claire
de ce que nous sommes censés faire.
Et ça date de seulement quelques années.
Cependant, je dois avouer
que j'étais très mal à l'aise
quand ces résultats sont tombés.
J'avais vraiment l'impression
que c'était condamnable
de recourir à une constante cosmologique
et qu'il ne fallait pas le faire.
Mais ce genre de chose vous aide à rester
critique par rapport à votre travail,
ce qui est très positif.
Au final, il faut considérer
les données et voir ce qu'elles disent.
Or, dans ce cas, elles paraissent indiquer
ou même semblent nous dire
que nous vivons
dans un Univers en accélération.
La chose a tout d'abord
été difficile à accepter,
mais les chercheurs s'habituent peu à peu
à l'idée d'un Univers en accélération.
Certains cependant,
avouent se sentir un peu
comme la reine blanche de Lewis Carroll,
qui se vantait de parvenir à croire
à six choses impossibles
avant le petit déjeuner.
Quel que soit le nom qu'on lui donne,
Énergie noire ou Constante cosmologique,
il s'agit là d'une chose étrange,
qui déconcerte même les experts.
Il faut du temps
pour s'habituer à la notion
d'un Univers qui va toujours plus vite.
Il est trop tôt pour exclure
quoi que ce soit,
mais s'il y a 10 ou 20 ans il était
difficile de faire des expériences
permettant de répondre à ces questions,
c'est désormais possible.
Il suffit d'attendre un peu
et avec l'évolution des techniques,
ce sujet sera bientôt élucidé.
Et je pense,
comme la majorité des astronomes,
que l'énergie noire est là pour de bon
et qu'il va falloir s'y habituer.
Les physiciens avaient une vague idée
de ce que pouvait être la matière noire,
différentes particules exotiques.
Mais pour ce qui
est de l'énergie noire, ils sèchent.
Il s'agit d'une énergie qui manifestement,
domine tout l'Univers,
qui ne s'agglomèrent pas,
ne crée pas de galaxies,
mais qui fournit une pression
qui distant l'Univers.
C'est vraiment bizarre.
L'expansion de l'Univers
a commencé à s'accélérer,
ce qui probablement n'avait pas eu lieu
depuis l'épisode d'inflation
au tout début de l'Univers.
Et voilà que ça recommence.
Et si quelqu'un vous dit
qu'il en connaît la raison,
ne le croyez pas.
Parce que nous ignorons complètement
pourquoi l'Univers est aussi
complexe et aussi baroque.
Rien de tel que la cosmologie
pour apprendre l'humilité.
L'Univers est si vaste,
notre place y est si minuscule
et notre entendement si limité.
Le Cosmos regorge de mystères,
mais aussi d'indices
permettant de les élucider.
À chaque instant,
il y a de nouvelles découvertes à faire.
L'énergie noire est quelque chose
de complètement surprenant.
D'abord, elle est répartie
de façon uniforme à travers l'Univers
et n'a donc pas d'effet particulier
sur les étoiles.
C'est simplement une propriété
de l'espace, une propriété du vide.
C'est comme si on nous disait : "Oubliez
tout ce que vous savez de l'Univers."
Sa principale composante,
à un peu plus de 50 %,
est une propriété de l'espace lui-même
et c'est vraiment étrange.
Nous ne savons pas la recréer
ni la mesurer autrement.
Nous n'avons pas de preuve
que le vide possède une énergie non nulle.
Et pourtant, nous sommes en train de dire
À mon avis, nous avons
encore beaucoup de travail devant nous,
car nous ne savons pas
ce qu'est cette fameuse matière noire.
Personne ne sait
de quoi elle est faite
et nous ne savons pas non plus
ce qu'est l'énergie noire.
Nous cumulons les données étranges
et il se pourrait que cela continue.
Et au fond rien ne nous permet
de dire ce qui est vrai ou faux.
Le fait que tout cela nous semble étrange,
signifie simplement que nous occupons dans
l'Univers une situation particulière.
Les cosmologistes du monde entier
sont en train de concevoir
une nouvelle génération
d'instruments puissants
pour sonder le fin fond de l'espace.
En plus de vérifier la conception
d'un Univers en accélération,
ils veulent regarder
11 ou 12 milliards d'années en arrière,
lorsque les premières étoiles
se sont allumées.
Ils veulent assister
à la naissance des galaxies
et personne ne sait
ou les mèneront ces recherches.
L'Univers nous réserve des surprises
et pourrait bien nous amener à tout
remettre en question une fois de plus.
Peut-être les générations futures
trouveront-elles le Big Bang
aussi vieillot et irréel,
que nous, la conception
moyenâgeuse de l'Univers
qui voyaient la terre
comme le centre du Cosmos ?
Les gens demandent souvent à quoi servent
toutes les recherches en cosmologie.
Après tout, nous sommes ici
et ce que sera l'Univers dans
100 milliards d'années importe aussi peu
que de savoir comment
nous sommes arrivés ici
au bout de 10 ou 15 milliards d'années.
À ceux qui pensent ça,
je ne sais que répondre.
La cosmologie est un sujet
d'amusement pour certains,
mais pour ceux qui s'y consacrent,
il est impossible de ne pas être convaincu
que la cosmologie est salutaire
et qu'il est bon de chercher à en savoir
plus sur nos origines et notre devenir.
C'est passionnant
de se dire qu'il y a des gens
qui travaillent jour et nuit
pour répondre à ces questions.
Voilà donc ce que nous savons
du Cosmos en ce début du XXIᵉ siècle.
Si vous avez parfois l'impression
que le monde vous échappe
et que tout va de plus en plus vite,
rassurez-vous, vous n'êtes pas le seul.
Si les cosmologistes ont raison,
c'est l'Univers tout entier qui s'étend
à une vitesse de plus en plus grande.
Alors profitons donc de l'espace
et du temps qui nous reste,
avant qu'ils ne s'échappent
dans toutes les directions.